what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
mcu and a lot of you really loved that
spider-man plot leak that i did a couple
of days ago
and i did too it was really great i hope
it happens and a lot of you were asking
me if the person that leaked this online
talked about a post credit scene for it
and yes they did it just kind of leads
into doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness and today
i'm doing a plot leak by that same
person for doctor strange too
so i just thought i would begin this
plot leak with the post-credits scene
for spider-man no way home now of course
none of this
is yet officially confirmed there are
things that have been confirmed in that
spider-man plot leak and if you haven't
seen that i'll link that up above
but of course with any plot leak usually
there are some things that are true
some things that are not true so take it
with a grain of salt but like i said
this is coming from the same person who
posted that spider-man no way home plot
leak that everybody seemed to love
so we'll start with the post-credits
scene for spider-man no way home and
then dive into the doctor strange
multiverse of
madness plot leak and if you're new and
you love the mcu and want to stay up to
date on the news and
leaks be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so in the spider-man
no way home league that i talked about a
couple of days ago there was
a mysterious orb that doctor strange was
using to kind of
keep the multiverse somewhat in order at
the end of the plot leak peter parker
tries to use that orb
to bring mj back to life the result is
the orb
breaking and doctor strange asks him
what did you do
and here is what is said to be the
rumored post-credit scene
doctor strange gathers the remains of
the broken orb and attempts to fix it
but is unsuccessful he then senses
something
hearing the faint sounds of children the
camera pans to his shoulder
revealing wanda standing behind him with
red
glowing eyes now this would be a super
awesome
post credit scene to see for spider-man
no way home because of course
right after that is going to be
multiverse of madness all these events
are connected
it's basically like a four movie story
we have one division
then loki which truly breaks open the
multiverse spider-man no way home which
starts to deal with it and then
multiverse of madness where
it all just goes crazy and of course
since wanda now has the darkhold and she
heard the voices of her children
of course she would look for doctor
strange the master of the mystic arts
and although they don't know each other
too well he is an
ally they did fight together and if
wanda realizes that her children are
trapped somewhere maybe in another
universe or a different realm
it makes perfect sense that she would go
to doctor strange so this would be a
cool post credit to see
and this goes into our multiverse of
madness leak
and just like i did the other day i'm
just going to read straight through it
and then we'll talk about it after
a multiversal war has begun thanks to
the events of loki
loki mobius and some tva agents appear
in two scenes
wanda's twins are stuck in the chaos
dimension and wanda wants to rescue them
no matter the cost
america chavez is a central part of the
plot she and wanda have an intense
confrontation early in the movie because
america chavez thinks that wanda is
responsible for the death of her mother
and the destruction of her home universe
strange and wanda have a big fight at
the end of act one
wanda wins and leaves strange for dead
he is rescued from plunging into the
dark dimension by tobey maguire
spider-man
dr strange is in a coma for a little bit
and wang comes to his aid
mordo makes an alliance with wanda but
he betrays and attempts to kill her
about halfway through
it's revealed that he's been working
with agatha harkness the entire time and
she confronts wanda and they have a
brief battle
wang is the sorcerer supreme of one
universe that will be briefly shown
c'thun wants to use america chavez's
powers to conquer
all of the universes christine palmer is
kidnapped and killed by
mordo her body will then be possessed by
clia's soul
it is from here that agatha harkness
thinks that this is all too much mordo
is doing way too much agatha exclusively
wanted revenge on wanda
nobody else and she doesn't want c'thun
taking over and before the final battle
agatha briefly makes amends with wanda
and leaves the leak says there is a
scene
similar to the portal scene in in-game
where actors that didn't get the roles
years ago
assemble playing alternate versions of
mcu heroes
fighting actors playing alternate
versions of mcu villains
this could be tom cruise as tony stark
emily blunt as black widow
john krasinski is captain america this
could be an extremely cool scene
strange wong wanda and chavez face off
against c'thun
wanda sacrifices herself to destroy
c'thun and end the multiversal war
and at the end all of the characters
believe that she is dead
at the end tommy and billy become
teenagers and strange locks mordo into a
dimensional prison
and then this says that there are three
rumored post-credits scenes
one is a scene where kane the conqueror
shows up setting up ant-man 3
quantum mania another rumored one is
agatha being recruited by valentina
allegra de fontaine
continuing the setup for the
thunderbolts or the dark avengers and
the third rumored one is wanda
reappearing alive
living in latviria with amnesia which i
have to say that is the one that i would
love to see because that would mean
doctor doom is coming doctor doom is
from latvia
and he's an incredibly powerful sorcerer
and we know that eventually he is going
to be coming and his mother was also
a very powerful witch so this all kind
of makes sense
that would definitely be the post credit
scene that i would be hoping for
especially because it would actually
show that wanda didn't really die she's
alive because i definitely don't think
that wanda is going anywhere
anytime soon as far as this plot leak is
concerned it's actually not
anywhere near as detailed as the
spiderman one is but to be fair the
person who posted these said that he saw
the entire spider-man no way home script
and he did not claim that for this leak
now what's curious about this plot leak
is that it shares some other scenes
that other plot leaks have said are
going to be in the film one is a fight
between doctor strange and wanda now the
previous league actually said that
doctor strange wins the fight whereas
this one says that wanda wins
and in all honesty this could go either
way doctor strange is the master of the
mystic arts but also keep in mind
that wanda now has the darkhold and
she's clearly going to be studying the
entire thing
learning a bunch of new abilities
abilities that doctor strange probably
won't have because keep in mind it's
very dark
magic now the dark hold was created by
c'thun who was the rumored villain
in this plot league of doctor strange ii
c'thun has a major connection to wanda
in the comics he actually planned on
using her body to take over the earth
dimension
she was his plan on how he was going to
get back to that dimension because he
was trapped outside of it and once he
got back and took over wanda he would
conquer
everything else which is basically what
this plot leak is saying that he wants
to do except he wants to use america
chavez because her ability is to open
portals to other dimensions a power
very suitable for a multiverse film the
other thing it mentions is toby
maguire's spider-man and he has actually
been heavily rumored to be appearing in
multiverse of madness as well as
spider-man no way home we'll have to
wait until we see no way home to
determine toby mcguire's fate and where
he ends up
but we know that he's going to be
working with doctor strange in no way
home
and i definitely think that everybody
would love for him to stick around
now mordo being in the film makes sense
as well and agatha being in the film
helping mordo out can also work the only
really weird thing i found about this
plot leak was the fact that christine
palmer is going to be kidnapped by mordo
and killed and then clya would possess
her body yes clea
is pretty much confirmed to be in this
film but i'm pretty sure they're going
to use a different actress for her
they're not going to use
rachel mcadams at least that's what the
rumors are from what we've heard doctor
strange and christine
have gone their separate ways and
everything kind of pointed to rachel
mcadams not appearing in this movie
however if it's for a very brief moment
of time in the movie and it sets up a
new character in which a new actress
would come
in i could definitely see that happening
and i could see a lot of this plot leak
happening a lot of it makes sense the
continuity is all there
again a lot is missing from this
specifically moments that doctor strange
is going to shine in this film because
remember it still is about him
even though he is going to share a lot
of the spotlight with wanda
it's still obviously his movie but let
me know what you think about this let me
know what you think about that
rumored leaked spider-man post credit
scene and this leak for doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness is it
something that you'd like to see
or do you hope for something completely
different
let me know in the comments down below
and don't forget to like the video and
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof